bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science consacrée aujourd'hui aux cinq
composantes de votre propre corps qui
sont plus anciennes que vous attend ça
vient de mon corps et ses plus vieux que
moi
il commence déjà vachement bien cet
épisode a déjà annoncé ans à l'homme et
non c'est tout simplement que chaque
partie de notre corps a une histoire et
cette histoire du fond des âges a laissé
des traces et cicatrices qui témoigne
d'une autre illustre ascendance et de
notre lointain passé
en effet si vous figuriez que votre
corps était de la belle ouvrage
une machine ingénieusement conçu pour
fonctionner à son plein potentiel
alors détrompez vous car si un ingénieur
se penchait sur notre cas voilà ce qu'il
verrait non mais régis le dossier humain
tu m'as fais quoi là pourquoi tu est
accolée à la pallice torah boury qui lui
sert à rien en plus ça risque de
s'infecter ah ba ba ba ça c'est pas mais
qu'est-ce que sa tête fut au bout de son
petit coup rachitique tu voulais pas y
connait les pointilleux aussi pour
indiquer le coupé non mais alors ça ça
je sais c'est sa mère hippie hippie la
pompe
non mais c'est n'importe quoi pourquoi
il vaut mieux la pompe qu'est ce que
c'est que tu es au coude et à la sortie
un dieu coûté à la sortie d'une pompe tu
crois qui va se passer quoi quand on va
le mettre en marche
non mais c'est ni fait ni à faire est le
nerf du ans pourquoi il fait un si long
détour alors qui passe juste à côté là
pourquoi t'as pas tracé une ligne droite
là hein c'est pas ma faute ok c'est
l'évolution ils nous ont dit voilà la
pression faite en un primate alors pas
forcément on fait ce qu'on peut mais
parce qu'on est au caire alors qu'en
toute réclamation
merci de vous adresser au département
évolution et oui c'est ça l'évolution
elle ne fait pas table rase du passé
elle innove à partir de ce qu'elle a
sous la main
elle est comme une fugue de bach elle
compose ses variations à partir d'un
thème de base entre la sent le nouvelle
note est pour beaucoup dans de nouvelles
mélodies par dessus ce qui existe déjà
et tout se mélange et tout se renouvelle
à perceptiblement l'évolution c'est
comme une symphonie qui se barrent
tirait par dessus les fondations du
bazert au wat a tout pété mon envolées
lyriques voilà tu m'a pourri mon gros
enfin je crois qu'on a compris l'idée la
merci l'évolution c'est comme un chimie
rien n'est jamais perdu et tout se
transforme
on a saisi le penser que je pense alors
sans plus attendre c'est parti pour ça
cinq des morceaux de veau qui sont plus
vieux que vous ne pourriez l'imaginer
dit ganso le cocon druillole les
mitochondries ce sont des petites
centrales d'énergie naturelle si petit
qu'il peut y avoir des dizaines à
l'intérieur d'une seule de vos cellules
notamment dans vos muscles tout les
mitochondries de votre corps absolument
tout vienne d'une poignée de
mitochondries que le corps de votre
maman a précautionneusement placée à
l'intérieur de l'eau bull que vous étiez
jadis elle a perdu les leurs et audry si
bien sûr il y en a dans les
spermatozoïdes mais les spermatozoïdes
ayant besoin d'énergie pour se propulser
toutes les mitochondries sont situés
dans leur flagelle flagelle qu'ils
perdent
lorsqu'il féconde l'ovule et ceci est
une conséquence importante
l'adn le code génétique de toutes vos
mitochondries est le même que celui des
mitochondries de votre mère qui est
d'ailleurs le même que celui de mai et
si on pousse le raisonnement
suffisamment loin alors on peut en
déduire que l'adn des mitochondries de
toute l'humanité est le même que celui
de notre mère à tous l'ancêtre commune
au genre humain lève mitochondrial au
moins à quelques mutations prêt et bien
entendu et séries sur les gâteaux en
comptant ces mutations il est possible
de déterminer combien de générations de
sépare d'elle et donc de calculer à
quelle époque et a vécu ce faisant les
généticiens ont calculé qu'elle aurait
donc vécu il ya entre 100 et 200 mille
ans et puisque les femmes d'afrique
subsaharienne porte en elle les traces
de l'adn mitochondrial le plus ancien il
est même possible de dire que eve
étaient africaine
c'est toujours très impressionnante de
faire ainsi parlait l'adn mais ça l'est
encore plus quand ce qu'il raconte colle
parfaitement avec ce que disent les
fossiles qui place l'origine de l'être
humain en afrique il est justement entre
120 et 200 milles
de quoi cela prendrait slam ordre certes
c'est un beau scénario et il serait
encore plus réussie avec une histoire
d'amour
alors du coup est ce que notre rêve
mitochondrial aurait fricoté avec un
adam et olalalala je traque tout site
qu'est ce que c'est que cette image
basséen derrière quoi normal non mais
alors si tu tiens vraiment à illustrer
nos propos tu seras gentil de tenir
compte du fait que l'humanité est
originaire d'afrique
r là c'est mieux d'accord d'accord bon
et l'adorent mitochondrial alors au
nigeria peut plus avoir de temps
mitochondrial parce que les
mitochondries ne se transmettent que par
les ovules
ah oui bon bah du coup il nous faut un
marqueur génétique qui soit typique des
hommes comme le chromosome y tient ça
devrait marcher avec un chromosome y
ah oui et en comptant les mutations du
chromosome y porter par les mâles de
notre espèce les généticiens sont
arrivés à la conclusion que la dent
chromosomiques a vécu il ya entre 150 et
400 millions 150 et 400 mille ans a fait
de la marche quand même
certes et vous l'aurez compris cette
dotation naissent largement ouverte la
possibilité que la dent chromosomiques
élèves mitochondrial n'est pas le cul en
même temps et certainement pas un
endroit non plus et ne se sont même
jamais croisé droit gros bobos arrête
ton char des murs par les aïeux mais
comment est-ce que c'est possible que le
père et la mère de l'humanité n'est pas
formé un couple ça n'a aucun sens alors
je t'explique
voici la population originelle de notre
espèce homo sapiens notre ancêtre commun
à tous
quand je dis population car à la
fidélité du couple chez homo sapiens à
l'âge de pierre
enfin vous voyez adorent iem doivent
faire partie de cette population quand
même non justement non voici les
descendants de cette population et voici
apparaître la dent chromosomique et puis
notre aide mitochondrial bien séparées a
je crois que j'ai saisi lille et la
voici les descendants d'adam et voici
ceux de sève et là c'est la population
chez qui les gêne de la dent
chromosomique et ceux de laives
mitochondrial se sont rencontrés et nous
enfin je vais dire tous les êtres
humains vivent aujourd'hui descendons
tous de cette population ou le
chromosome y d'adam et les mitochondries
de haybes se côtoient c'est pour ça
qu'on les retrouve chez tous les êtres
humains mais que les datations ne
concordent pas bah du coup c'est grave a
buzzé d'appeler ces deux-là adam et eve
ça fait genre figures bibliques et tout
le toutim alors qu'en fait ce sont juste
les plus anciens porteurs des deux
marqueurs génétiques typique à chaque
sexe s
sûr qu'il faut pas prendre les
appellations adam et eve au pied de la
lettre la dent chromosomiques nintendo
que pour les gènes du chromosome y élève
mitochondrial net unef que pour les
jeunes des mitochondries ryan plus la
vraie populations ancestrales de
l'humanité c'est celle où les deux lots
de gènes issus de ces deux là se sont
retrouvés ensemble pour la première fois
tenez vous le pour dit la génétique ne
retrace que l'histoire des gènes pas
directement celle des gens qui les
portent
nérac le 3ème revo chakraborty car il va
être du temps pour nous de vous parler
du troisième trimestre
oui ça sur le coup 1 à 3 et merci je
faut un nom le troisième oeil dont on va
parler se trouve au sommet du crâne chez
les quelques reptiles actuel qui en
possède encore un comme le ce fait nos
dons donc si nous devions posséder à
troisième oeil
il serait plus certainement situé au
milieu de tas flamboyant tignasse un
beau père est alors pourquoi tu dis
qu'ils en possèdent encore un ça veut
dire que les autres ont perdu c'est bien
ça à l'origine tous les vertébrés
terrestres ou aquatiques posséder un
troisième oeil la plupart l'ont ensuite
perdu les poissons les crocodiles et les
mammifères par exemple il troisième oeil
ne voit pas les images par contre ils
servent les arts actuels à mesurer la
longueur des journées
il est relié à une glande la glande
pinéale ou et peas qui agit un peu comme
un calendrier naturel qui indiquerait
directement au cerveau maintenant c'est
le jour
maintenant c'est la nuit là les jours
raccourcissent donc ça doit être libère
maintenant les jours rallongent donc on
approche de l'été la glande pinéale est
un peu comme un calendrier
elle est utile pour qu'elle et les
cycles de reproduction afin que tout le
monde batifolent au bon moment elle
régule aussi les rythmes liées au
sommeil et sert à savoir quel est le
meilleur moment pour se dorer la pilule
au soleil
mais si c'est si utile alors pourquoi
autant d'animaux y compris à sang froid
se passe d'un troisième oeil ça c'est
une grande question
disons que nous autres avons simplement
d'autres organes sensibles à la lumière
qui sont capables de remplir le même
rôle que le troisième oeil et qui ne
s'en prive pas j'ai nommé les îles et
oui la structure la base génétique et le
développement du troisième âge sont
exactement les mêmes que celles de nos
propres yeux pers dès lors pourquoi
s'embêter avec un troisième a dit donc
l'isna faire apparaître un lien entre
eux pour ensuite le faire disparaître
non mais c'est encore première
d'optimiser tous à la bbc
l'administration de la nature vous savez
ils sont pas avares de procédure surtout
pour les paperasses alors ils savent pas
faire les choses simplement en quoi mais
ce n'est pas parce que nous n'avons plus
de ce troisième est que nous n'avons pas
de glande pinéale regardez là ici oui le
tout petit point rouge là elle est
toujours là minuscule mais bien présente
et elle remplit toujours son rôle de
régulation des cycles biologiques c'est
par exemple à cause d'elle car décalage
horaire vous fait si mal
et que vous faites des réserves en hiver
mais sachez aussi un peu à cause de
repas de fête et ses petits boutons tout
juste un amas de cellules au coeur de
notre cerveau si tout ce qui reste du
globe troisième oeil de vos ancêtres
libre et maliens les prêts maliens ont
vécu il ya entre 320 et 250 millions
d'années et ont été les tout premiers
vertébrés terrestres à devenir de grands
herbivores et de super prédateurs ils
ont vécu partout même chez nous et ils
ont régné sur le monde durant des
millions d'années et ce bien avant que
les tous premiers dinosaures
n'apparaissent des carnivores à dents de
sabre des herbivores géants avec deux
tortues des colosses au crâne en ait
deux camps de monstrueuses des petits
insectes yvan vivant dans les terriers
les chasseurs asseyant brûlures dorsale
ou bien encore des sortes d'hippopotames
sont autant de représentants de la
diversité de cette mémorable ligne et
qui donne à jour naissant surtout
premiers mammifères ils sont bien trop
souvent confondue avec les dinosaures
alors qu'ils ont presque tous vécu avant
eux ils sont les grands oubliés de nos
livres de science car car on a la
fâcheuse tendance à trop souvent les
appeler des reptiles ma malien la notion
de reptile est une notion qui s'applique
relativement bien aux espèces vivantes
d'aujourd'hui les créatures écailleuse
qui pondent des oeufs à sang froid et
réponses sur le sol pourtant déjà là il
ya un problème les oiseaux les oiseaux
sont génétiquement plus proche des
crocodiles que les crocodiles ne sont
proches des autres reptiles
donc il faudrait exclure les crocodiles
des reptiles ou alors dire que les dozos
sont des reptiles pas facile à mettre un
appelé toutes ces petites boules de
plumes des rétifs ça fait déjà grincer
les dents alors maintenant imaginez si
vous prenez les plus anciens
représentants de la lignée des
mammifères comme les célèbres dit mais
trop tôt et que vous vous mettez à
appeler ça un reptile aussi at-il malien
alors là le mot reptiles ne veut
absolument plus rien dire du tout
puisque au final vous y ranger des
espèces qui n'y sont apparentés que de
façon très très indirecte les prix le
malien avait déjà acquis plusieurs
caractères en commun avec les mammifères
comme la possible absence des cayes
encore que les écailles fossilise assez
mal des soins parentaux et même 10 métro
dont 2 mais d'avoir un mode de vie
nocturne
ce qui laisse envisager la possibilité
qu'il n'ait pas eu le sens si froid que
ça donc pourquoi appeler ça des reptiles
malien pourquoi ne pas appeler ça des
mammifères reptilien plutô t as regardé
celui là il pond des oeufs
on pourrait dire que c'est un ami vers
les petits seins en arrêt
faire ouais mamar est il vrai aucun pré
me malien c'est bien les traits manière
comme le dit métro dans avec tous ou
presque
un trou au sommet du crâne pour laisser
passage troisième oeil qui devait comme
chez les lézards actuelle être relié à
la glande pinéale situé dans cette
partie du cerveau qu'on dit reptilienne
noter qu'on ne parle de cerveau
reptilien que par opposition aux néo
cortex qui est la couche la plus
superficielle du cerveau et qui est
typique des mammifères sinon le cerveau
des bras et peut-il et celui du 10 métro
dont était déjà très différents séparés
par plusieurs millions d'années
d'évolution puis certainement un lien
avec l'apparition du métabolisme à son
chouchou
l'épiné à la perdu sa fonction et a
disparu chez nous mais me faire tout ce
qu'il nous en reste c'est cette petite
glande pinéale atrophiée ce fantôme de
l'évolution ce reliquat de notre
lointain passé enfoui tout au fond de
notre cerveau mais ici comme rené
descartes vous pensiez que la pinéale
été le siège de l'âme alors une forêt on
faire à l'idée que lesdits métro dont
doivent prendre une sacrée place au
paradis
l'adn notre code génétique c'est une
molécule incroyablement longue mais
microscopique contenus dans vos cellules
cette molécule est en fait une immense
lignes de code dans laquelle sont
inscrits les instructions pour
construire qu'un livre et entretenir à
naître vivre votre adn c'est votre
disque dur sauf que votre code n'est pas
écrire en deux caractères 0 et 1 mais en
quatre caractères à poura bénigne c'est
pour cytosine j'ai pour guanine été pour
timmy tous les êtres vivants actuelle
sans exception partage rigoureusement le
même système de codage adn même si la
séquence des lettres est différente
d'une espèce à une autre cela signifie
que l'adn est aussi vieux que la vie
elle-même 3,5 à 4 milliards d'années et
que nous l'avons tous hérité d'une
cellule unique
l'ancêtre commun de tous les êtres
vivants lucas pour last universal common
ancestor ah non là je taille car c'est
pas tout à fait laniel et peut-être
aussi vieux que lucas mais lucas n'est
pas l'appuyer cellules vivantes ils
n'étaient que l'ancêtre commun des
espèces actuelles ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu des trônes yvan
plusieurs encore comment ça plus anciens
du tu veux dire des êtres vivants sans
adn non je veux juste dire qu'il y avait
d'autres êtres vivants avant lucas mais
qu'ils se sont éteints preuve en est que
l'adn en codant pour des protéines sert
de base lui même pour fabriquer un être
vivant mais que l'adn ne peut pas copier
tout seul il a besoin de certaines
protéines pour cela protéines qui
doivent aussi être grevés par deux à
damas alors maire c'est comme le coup de
l'oeuf et de la poule quoi il faut déjà
de l'adn pour fabriquer un être vivant
pour fabriquer de l'adn et donc il a
bien fallu tu es quelque chose pressé de
l'adn et ce quelque chose qui est
contenu dans les cellules vivantes plus
ancienne que lucas l'ancêtre de l'adn
qui sortent tout ça c'est assez flou
alors pour mieux vous illustrer ce
propos on va plutôt vous parler des
baleines les baleines actuelle se
nourrissent de plancton en filtrant
l'eau de mer à l'aide de leurs fans ont
les femmes ne sont pas les dents ce sont
des excroissances de kératine comme des
cheveux ou des ongles qui pousse sur le
palais les premières baleines elle
n'avait pas de fanon et comme la plupart
des mammifères elle avait des dents mais
cédant était bien particulière elle leur
servait à filtrer l'eau le phoque
crabiers qui s'est nourri de cette
manière possible des dents très
similaires les fossiles montrent que les
dents n'ont pas été subitement remplacé
par les fans
lors de l'évolution des baleines mais
qu'il y a eu une période de coexistence
des baleines avec des fans ont aidés
dans le système de filtrage par les
dents a en quelque sorte servi
d'assistant au système de filtrage
parfois non quand il commençait à
apparaître et était encore peu efficace
ce dernier l'a ensuite surpasser puis
naturellement remplacé remplacer
maintenant le mot filtrage par le bon
codage et vous obtenez l'histoire de
l'ancêtre de l'adn le système de codage
par adn a dû être précédée par un
système de codage chimiquement plus
simple et plus basique ce système a
servi d'armature sur et autour duquel
s'est construit le système de codage à
des fi nalement l'adn s'y trouvait être
un système plus efficace qui est
complètement supplanté l'ancien système
lucas était né la capacité fondamentale
de l'adn et donc de la vie en général
c'est de faire des copies de lui même
l'adn comme la vie qu'il soutient est
une molécule qui se reproduit donc la
molécule échafaudage a pu être à peu
près n'importe quel type de molécules
temps qu'elle possédait cette capacité
fondamentale la reproduction
aujourd'hui le graphique qui se compose
un empilement de feuilles d'un atome
d'épaisseur de carbone pur est un
cristal qui est capable de se reproduire
le graphite c'est la matière de la mine
de votre crayon de bois et il est très
facile d'en détacher d'effeuiller par
simple frottement
il a aussi la capacité d'attirer les
atomes de carbone qui entourent et qui
parfois s'accumulent jusqu'à former une
nouvelle couche du cristal
c'est un processus lent et peu efficace
de reproduction mais qui dit
reproduction dit descendance avec
modification et qui dit descendance avec
modification dit sélection naturelle des
lignes et de cristaux se reproduisant le
plus rapidement et c'est ainsi dans ces
théoriciens que la vie a pu émerger de
la matière minérale au fil des
générations de clis de grafite ou de
quoi que ce soit d'autre qui lui
ressemble d'ailleurs ceci n'est bien sûr
qu'un modèle purement théorique pourtant
quand on regarde la chimie du vivant on
remarque qu anatomy et centrale
prédominant le carbone évidemment
maintenant pensez-y le graphite est lui
aussi composé de carbone et ça c'est
peut-être le signe que c'est lui
l'ancêtre minérales de lundi
numérotée le faire le dire c'est bien
mais le faire c'est mieux
chaud alors là on n'a pas froid aux yeux
maintenant on attaque les composants de
votre corps qui sont plus vieux que
votre corps mais qui sont aussi plus
vieux que la vie sur la terre elle-même
seller de l'instant souvent terrestre
fait sa vie en quelque sorte oui notre
corps le cirque fait de cellules de la
matière vivante intéresse mais les
cellules elles sont faites de molécules
qui sont elles mêmes faibles at home et
ses atomes sont bien plus vieux que
l'origine de la vie sur terre ou que
notre terre elle même le faire et le
quatrième élément le plus abondant de la
croûte terrestre
et si l'on retrouve du sein du cuivre du
cobalt du sélénium et même de l'or dans
votre censure sous forme de traces un ne
commencez pas à chercher le faire il est
par contre lui omniprésent cette belle
couleur rouge ne vous rapelle d'en créer
un et oui la rouille votre s'en est
plaint d'euros il diffère oxydé en fait
contenu à l'intérieur de vos globules
rouges le faire s'oxyde avec une
facilité déconcertante et notre sens est
approprié cette propriété qui lui permet
de transporter cette denrée essentielle
au fonctionnement de nos organes qu'elle
oxygène le fer est un atom relativement
lourd et aucun phénomène existant sur
terre n'était assez puissant pour voir
laquelle un tel type d'atomes pour qu'un
dôme de fer se forme il faut du silicium
il rassure nucléaires générant une
énergie inimaginable comme seuls des
étoiles en fin de vie sont capables d'en
produire cette réaction nucléaire est
généralement la dernière de la vie d'une
étoile car après cela elle s'effondre
sur elle-même puis devient une supernova
explosion disperse alors le faire tout
récemment formé autour d'elle puis la
gravité rassembler les atomes à 2 go et
un nouveau cycle recommence
c'est ainsi pense-t-on que le faire qui
composent notre terre et notre sens est
née à partir de l'explosion d'un soleil
d'un autre système solaire qui a existé
en lieu et place de notre propre système
solaire à nous mais bien longtemps avant
le nôtre
en fait il existe sur terre des éléments
bien plus lourd que le faire ce qui veut
dire que par un mais deux systèmes
solaires ont certainement précédé le
nôtre et et oui notre soleil n'a que 5
milliards d'années et l'univers en a
quatorze que croyez vous qu'il se soit
passé pendant ces neuf premier milliard
d'années vous rendez vous
le faire du sang qui coule dans vos
veines et de la même origine que celui
qui rejoint dans le noyau de notre
planète
franchement si après ça vous trouvez de
plus belle histoire à raconter à vos
enfants
l'hydrogène
tout le monde le sait l'eau c'est la vie
si votre corps est aujourd'hui constitué
d'environ 80% d'eau et que vous vous
battez chaque jour contre la
déshydratation pour maintenir cette
moyenne c'est à cause de vos lointains
ancêtres aquatique qui ont passé les
trois premiers milliards d'années de
l'évolution de la vie à concocter les
diverses mixture indispensables à leur
survie dans cet élément l'eau est
composée de trois atomes d'oxygène et 2
d'hydrogène les atomes d'oxygène ont une
histoire semblable à celle des atomes de
fer dans le coeur des étoiles
mais ce d'hydrogène ont une origine
lointaine bien plus lointaines car ils
se sont formés pour la première fois
lors du big bang
jeudi big bang
ben non mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
vieux sont dégueulasses moi je voulais
une explosion mais ça monte yeux ça
c'est le vrai sens du bit banques tel
que reconstitué par la mission planck à
partir du fond diffus cosmologique ans
et moi un pad à son explosion de loin
c'est sûr techniquement juste alors
c'est pas une explosion le big bang à la
non mais ya pas vraiment de mots pour
décrire ce que des pigments mais ce qui
est sûr en tout cas c'est que t'as pas
là comme c'est pas le bon soit soit bon
l'hydrogène a donc été le premiers
atomes formé lors de l'apparition de
l'univers il est aujourd'hui toujours le
principal composant de la matière
visible et notre composition chimique
reflète parfaitement celle de l'univers
car c'est bien l'hydrogène l'atome le
plus fréquent de notre corps comme un
vrai petit morceaux d'univers vous ne
l'aurez deviné c'est par fusions
successives des atomes d'hydrogène puis
de leurs produits dérivés entre lors de
réactions nucléaires titanesque qui ont
lieu au coeur des étoiles que toute la
matière visible a pu se former
on ne le redira jamais assez dans
l'univers rien ne se perd rien ne se
crée tout se transforme de fait toute la
matière tout ce qui existe dans
l'univers est enfant du big bang
ce qui fait des étoiles nos soeurs nos
cousines si vous préférez on attribue
trop souvent et à tort le qualificatif
d' inerte à la matière non vivante mais
l'univers même s'il n'a pas fait de
matière vivante est tout sauf linéaire
la matière si des places fusionnent
tremble explose et exactement comme pour
les êtres vivants les étoiles comme
notre soleil en une naissance
grandissent voyage centre des bords
vivre une vie tumultueuse puis meurt et
leur matière et recyclés comme nous les
étoiles de consommer de l'énergie afin
de ne pas voir certains de leurs flammes
l'univers tout entier est en mouvement
il s'étend et toute cette matière que
nous considérons à tort comme inertes se
meut imperceptiblement à une échelle que
nous ne pouvons simplement pas
comprendre tout juste envisage et
finalement si vous avez du mal à croire
que la ville
s'extraire de la matière minérale il
faut que nous sommes tous fait des mêmes
at home et finalement pas grand chose de
la matière soit disant inerte pour que
nous considérions comme vivantes juste
la capacité de se reproduire dans fond
qu'est-ce qui différencierait à soleil
capable de faire des copies de lui même
d'une bactérie
si ce n'est sa taille alors tout bien
considéré nous ne sommes pas si
différent de nos ancêtres les étoiles
merci à tous ces épisodes étaient quand
même vachement je prendrais bien petit
bernadino art yverdon tu veux dire les
dinosaures ayant régné sur terre pendant
160 millions d'années il est donc
presque statistiquement impossible qu'il
n'y ait pas au moins une molécule de
receveurs qui n'est pas une fois fait
partie intégrante du corps à dinosaures
durant tout ce temps fut touché alors si
les homéopathes ont raison je suis en
train de boire du dinosaure couler